[Music]
Wizards of Waverly Place the movie yet
another Disney Channel movie based on a
Disney Channel show that I have never
watched honestly I didn't even though
this is where Selena Gomez came from
once again seeing how I haven't seen the
show I can't really compare it to the
original source material but I can say
for a newcomer I actually followed it
surprisingly well and also as a newcomer
I actually didn't see it as that bad my
first initial thought was it was gonna
be another Harry Potter spin-off like
some of these other Disney Channel
movies but that's not really quite the
direction it goes elet play by selena
gomez is part of a family of wizards
that lives on Waverly Place but they
don't stay there long as the mother
decides they need to grow closer
together so the family takes a vacation
but the teens being normal teens are not
having a lot of fun Alex eventually feel
so shut in that she accidentally uses
her powers to make it seem like her mom
and dad never met the spell works the
parents have no idea who each other are
or the kids and they seem like
completely different people when they're
single using their magic you're
responsibly not caring that much about
other people all the usual stuff but it
looks like they only have 48 hours
before reality sets in and the kids
themselves will disappear in fact their
memories already seem to be going but it
just so happens they come across a
half-assed magician who used to be a
wizard
in fact the parrot used to be his
girlfriend who has a secret map to the
stone of dreams a magical device you can
make one wish upon that will come true
so it's Harry Potter / even-steven /
Indiana Jones / Beach vacation that all
these Disney Channel movies seem to like
to go on upon hearing the plot you
wouldn't think very much of the movie
and truth be told its strength is not in
its writing its strength is in its
performances in a lot of these Disney
Channel movies you always kind of feel
like these actors are shoved together
really fast and yet they're supposed to
act like a family like they've known
each other for years and you can't boy
mom I doubt they have much rehearsal and
they have to just go but here because I
think they did have years of being on a
show they really have a camaraderie they
have the one-liners they have the
zingers but they never seem to mean they
seem like the kind of normal family
would make
take for example this scene where the
father asked for the one back just
either one come on give me one now
wenton down him mimicking him wouldn't
be that funny but because the
performances seem very real it works
that really is the saving grace of this
movie I legitimately like watching these
people nobody seemed out of place no one
was giving an awkward acting job they
all seemed legitimately believable even
something as silly as this magician
talking to his parrot it's so dumb but
by God every minute he's on screen I
believe that parrot is his girlfriend
she sells it as well as Jimmy Stewart
does making believe there's a rabbit in
the room yeah yeah but I know you know
you were sentenced to 50 years in
feathers could you take the stone first
it disappears forever you're kind of
good at this Helen they not only work in
context of the comedy but they work in
connection to the other characters
I totally buy every single one of their
relationships and they would act how
they're acting towards one another the
only part where I get a little lost and
again maybe this comes back to having to
know the show is that there's this
competition at the end that they have to
go through in order to become real
wizards but it you know Springs out of
nowhere in that they talked about a
little bit but you don't think it's
gonna be the climax they both have to
try in order to become real wizards so
that they can get those spells to put
everything right and yeah it's pretty
it's neat it's creative but I just don't
think it was fully explained or worked
into the story that great especially
when you find out what saves the day it
almost kind of seems pointless but still
most of the funny moments work it looks
nice it's creative and even some of the
dramatic moments it bull's-eyes and
again that comes from the surprising
believability of these performances does
every joke work no does every line work
no are there awkward moments what Disney
Channel movie doesn't have that but
still at the end of the day I like
watching this family their snarky but
you can tell they love each other and it
doesn't feel manipulative it's the same
way malcolm in the middle' act so mean
to each other at the end of the day you
know they're a unique unit and they
still function as a caring family that's
more than enough for me to say this
ain't half bad
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you